who's on the well there's so many female
mount rushmore these days well it's
tough to be a lady i feel like in comedy
because you're you're the lady comic
there's so many funny
comics who are women that like don't get
their due because it's almost like you
heard in the 80s they could only be one
funny black guy it was like richard
pryor then it was eddie murphy then it
was rock chris rock yeah and you got amy
you got jessica kirsten you got uh
carmen lynch laurie kalmar there's so
many funny uh ladies and taylor
tomlinson you know killing it so uh
i don't know i don't and i don't love
the goat thing you know who's the goat
and everybody's like chappelle's the
goat or louie's the goat or bill burr's
the goat i'm like ah it always changes
some people are better at this kind of
stuff so
it's like saying who's the best porn
star lisa ann hello
what are we talking about she is pretty
great yeah she's great we're all taking
it up the ass
um
watch out for amber joy lane by the way
for on that list oh yeah there you go so
um
but i agree yeah the goat is like an
annoying argument there's only the one
but who are your comedy heroes like
who's on your mount rushmore just yours
okay well i'm a weirdo cause i i go way
back i like i like groucho marx who's a
guy from the 40s 30s and 40s silent
mustache well not silent but mustache
yeah
i feel like okay gotcha all right my bad
yeah
but then i love i grew up loving bill
murray was like my hero as a kid i love
larry david so he's like my number one
but then greg geraldo uh rest in peace
jordan
yeah
love carl and carlin's fun cause he's
getting all this uh [ __ ] after he died
like everybody's like the left claims
him then the right's like what about
this joke
you know carl was the quintessential
comedian when both sides hate you i
think you're doing something right
correct um so carlin uh seinfeld was
huge for me chris rock was huge for me
louis ck bill has to be norm norm is it
my top five for sure i i totally am
biting him a little bit
um
you just both have these like very
signature voices all right hey i'll take
it but different why does he remind you
of norma mcdonald a lot a lot in the
best ways thank you
a good looking young
norm mcdonald oh he was handsome
yeah you mentioned david tell is he on
your list david tell love david till
david tells tough because i know him so
i should put him more on the pedestal
but i forget because he's just like such
a killer comic but uh
yeah david tells
i would say the goat but hey look i'm
gonna kind of put you on the spot here
um you know jerry seinfeld called you
the best young and up and coming all
right he was drinking a lot he was yeah
clearly he's drunk
if you could say somebody that's young
that you see doing their thing new york
city comedies or someone you're like yo
this kid watch out for this guy because
they're going to come back and say mark
norman called so and so and so the best
who do you think well there's a there's
a couple guy uh sean patton is hilarious
he doesn't get his dude he's got chad
daniels uh fahim anwar is really funny
like there's all these guys and gals
hold on let me name some women here so i
don't get yelled at on twitter but uh
yeah i named a bunch of ladies at the
beginning but yeah yeah you did great so
you don't see a lot of people i'm gonna
add one more to that let's watch out new
york city uh marcelo hernandez from the
show there you go our boy that uh you
met the other day yeah young up and
coming dina hashem very funny very funny
comedian but i just think funny isn't
number one anymore like now it's like
what's your thing are you trans are you
in a wheelchair are you asian yeah you
know funny like there's a lot of guys
funnier than fluffy but fluffy is fluffy
you know that's really what it takes to
be i'm not saying he's not funny but it
takes
more you gotta have a gimmick you have a
character you gotta be likable you gotta
have heat you know funny is that you
need to be a trans asian in a wheelchair
who happens to be overweight and fluffy
and boom they would get a deal instantly
i guarantee like there's more space for
more different kinds of comedians now
because we have access to your exact uh
target audience
tick tock so there can be somebody in
all of those niches because there is
enough of an audience for those people
to survive even if they're not applying
to
like the entire demographic
[Music]